any doubts about what Iran might do if
attacked the man who would lead the
fight put to rest I'm not gonna walk on
it
our reaction will be absolute and we
will respond powerfully to anyone who
wants his land to become a battlefield
we will never let Iranian land become a
battlefield and we will fight to the end
know where we'll be safe be careful how
did you Hussain salami took charge of
the Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps
earlier this year his warning to Iran's
enemies came at a ceremony to unveil new
exhibits at the War Museum in Tehran
exhibits which are no doubt especially
prized drones seized or shot down by
Iranian forces today we see the largest
collection of global drones in this
museum and people can closely observe
different kinds of drones that mostly
belonged to America this museum serves
as a lesson to our enemies to those who
threaten the nation of Iran Iran is
investing heavily in developing weapons
to respond leaders say to the ongoing US
military buildup in the Middle East Iran
has also been able to reinforce its
armory by reverse engineering the kind
of American and British equipment on
display here attacks on Saudi Arabian
oil facilities earlier this month have
renewed fears that Iranian military
support for Houthi fighters in Yemen is
what made them possible
but answering questions about how much
material support if any Iran is giving
the Houthis was not on the day's agenda
instead a celebration of what Iranians
consider important victories in the
wider battle for regional control the
most prestigious trophy a wreckage of
one of the Pentagon's most sophisticated
drones a Global Hawk spy plane downed by
Iranian forces in June and here the very
same surface-to-air missile defense
system that shot it down it was actually
transported to the capital from the
south of the country where it was
deployed to try and curate this kind of
visual equation predator and prey
showcased in the same place to
illustrate the point Iran can't seem to
make often enough if its enemies are
looking for a fight
Iran will give them one Zane bus Ravi
al-jazeera Tehran